Also wir haben am Anfang schon mal versucht, diese Begrifflichkeit Kinderpornografie noch mal ein bisschen schärfer zu fassen. Wie wir gesagt haben, das ist eine Dokumentation, eine Abbildung von Kindesmissbrauch. Also um vielleicht auch noch mal ganz klar zu Pornografie zu trennen, die ja auch zumindest bei uns in Deutschland, das ist ja auch nicht überall auf der Welt so, jetzt erst mal relativ liberal gehandhabt wird. Also man kann einfach in eine Videothek gehen, sich da irgendwie einen Pornofilm holen. Also voll Erotik, wie es ja auch so schön heißt. Also wo dann auch wirklich alles komplett zu sehen ist.
Also es ist nicht strafbar.
Keine Kinder, keine Tiere, keine Toten.
Und um das einfach mal von der Begrifflichkeit ein bisschen zu trennen. Also einfach zu sagen, okay, da werden irgendwie Kinder missbraucht. Das klingt vielleicht auch noch mal oder ist einfach noch mal begrifflich vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen geschärft von Kinderpornografie. Weil wir zusätzlich auch noch mal noch mal einen kleinen Exkurs in die jüngste Gesetzgebung. Wir haben jetzt einen neuen Begriff, der heißt Kinder- und Jugendpornografie. Das sind also Abbildungen von Kindern, Jugendlichen in, sagt man, unnatürlicher sexueller Haltung. Wie ist die Formulierung da?
Ich komme mit Schwimmen. Mit geschlechtsbetonten.
Unnatürlich geschlechtsbetonter Haltung, genau. Sogenannte Posing-Fotos, die jetzt auch darunter fallen.
Fällt darunter eigentlich auch die Dr.Sommer-Seite in Abravo?
Das kommt drauf, als ob es dich erregt oder nicht, weil dann ist es Pornografie.
Aber es geht ja gar nicht darum, ob es dich erregt, sondern um die unnatürliche, ich habe schon wieder den Begriff vergessen, die unnatürliche Darstellung. Interessant ist natürlich auch, wie es mit vielen Kunstwerken ist. Also es gibt ja eine Geschichte der Kunst, gibt es eine ganze Menge Werke, zum Beispiel auch das Plattencover von Scorpions, die ja dann möglicherweise da drunter fallen. Und da wird sich jetzt zeigen, wie sich da die Rechtsprechung einpendelt. Es ist zum Beispiel gerade vor kurzem eine Verfassungsklage gegen diesen neuen Paragraph 184c Strafgesetzbuch eingereicht worden von Hassler, also eine große Erotikfirma. Und zwar hatten die ein Problem damit, dass sie ihre Teens, die zwar keine Teens sind, aber natürlich aus Marketingaspekten so genannt werden, nicht mehr so nennen dürfen oder dass sie befürchten, dass diese sogenannten Teens dann verboten sind. Weil nämlich auch Darstellungen, wo behauptet wird, das wären Minderjährige, auch unter diesen Paragraphen fallen. Also wir merken schon, da ist es tatsächlich ein ziemlich großes Feld. Was ist jetzt eigentlich Pornografie?
Auch schon wieder am Anfang der Sendung zum Thema Zensur im Internet, dass es so richtig gar kein rechtliches Korsett, keine rechtliche Grundlage dafür gibt. Also richtig Gesetze, die schon feststehen, das Ganze basiert. Und damit dann zurück zur Frage von Stefan. Wer bestimmt jetzt eigentlich wirklich diese Filterregeln?
Und was ich vielleicht noch dazugefügen wollte, die Frage ist ja dann auch noch, was passiert überhaupt, wenn wir erstmal überhaupt diese ganzen Sachen haben, diese ganze Technik, wenn hier erstmal alles am Start ist und so, und was wird dann als nächstes noch gefiltert? Das ist ja dann auch noch eine Frage, die dann an der ganzen Sache irgendwie noch mit anknüpft. Weil ich kann mir vorstellen, dass irgendwie, wenn jetzt gesagt wird, Kinderpornografie verboten, dann kommen jetzt die Nächsten und sagen, okay, die Neonazis wollen wir auch aus dem Netz haben. Und dann als nächstes wird irgendwie, was weiß ich, Firesharing oder sowas verboten. Und ich weiß nicht, wo wir denn da hinkommen, das mal ich mir irgendwie ganz böse aus. Wenn wir jetzt irgendwie anfangen zu filtern und so. Das ist so mein Grundsatz eigentlich. Aber ja.
Na ja, das ist wie bei den Mautbrücken. Die wurden ja auch aufgestellt mit der Ansage, dass das nur zu Abrechnungszwecken dient.
Und mittlerweile wären sie zu Verkehrsüberwachen genutzt?
Ja, genau. Das ist immer so eine Frage. Also wenn man Technik erschafft und dann kommen irgendwie Leute und haben ihre Begehrlichkeiten und dann sagt der wieder, ich will das und naja, dann haben wir nachher irgendwie einen Überwachungsstarter. Vorfürchte ich mich so ein bisschen.
Und genau das ist die Diskussion, die wir ja heute auch versuchen, hier ein bisschen abzubilden im Chaosradio.
Ja, ich hätte auch nochmal so eine Frage, um nochmal so ein bisschen ins Technische zurückzukommen. Entschuldigung, Jakob. Ich hätte mal eine Frage und zwar, wie sieht es denn aus mit I2P oder Freenet? Kann man sich damit irgendwie gut vor Zensur schützen? Also ich kann ja vielleicht so ein bisschen ausholen, dass es irgendwie der Ansatz ist, dass man quasi die Seiten nicht auf Server packt, sondern dass man das halt irgendwie...
Als Hidden Services? Sozusagen als Hidden Services?
Ja, das funktioniert dann so, dass man es halt nicht auf Server packt, sondern dass man es dezentral alles verwaltet und so. Ja, dass es dann auf die User verteilt. Das ist so ähnlich wie Peer-to-Peer. Ich muss dazu sagen, dass ich auch nicht ganz so viel Ahnung davon habe.
Das zeigt einen wichtigen Punkt. Also so Featermaßnahmen kann man natürlich immer besser machen, aber das Internet ist nun mal so gebaut, dass Dinge dezentral sind, dass Filter in irgendeiner Form nur begrenzt funktionieren können, weil man immer nur... Ja, also es ist quasi ein Katzen-Maus-Spiel. Habt man ja in der DNS-Geschichte gesehen, irgendwie sie filtern DNS, die Leute benutzen andere DNS-Server, jetzt müssen sie irgendwie mal ein bisschen tiefer und Proxys dazwischen schalten und so. Und das führt alles zunächst. Das ist ein technisches, ja noch nicht mal Wettrüsten, weil das zu umgehen wirklich, das kann man nicht als Rüsten bezeichnen, sondern das ist...
Es geht im Sand, also ich sehe da auch keine Lösung für. Also ich finde, da wird immer irgendwie wieder was sein, irgendjemand wird sich um was ausdenken und dann ist die ganze Filtergeschichte wieder für die Katz.
Zum Thema Filterregeln, Stefan, haben wir vielleicht jetzt einen Gesprächspartner, der da einiges Interessantes dazu sagen könnte. Der hat nämlich einen langen Artikel dazu geschrieben. Florian Walther vom Scusi-Blog. Du namen Florian. Hallo. Du hast solche Filterlisten analysiert. Kannst du vielleicht auf diese Frage, wer diese Filterregeln aufstellt und wie sie aussehen, eine genauere Antwort geben?
Nee, wer die aufstellt und wie die... also wer die aufstellt, darauf kann ich auch keine Antwort geben. Ich meine, in Deutschland sind die ja auch noch nicht in Place sozusagen. In den anderen Ländern, in denen sowas schon gibt, also in den Niederlanden, in Schweden, in Finnland, in Norwegen, in der Schweiz, da werden die meistens von zentralen Polizeidienststellen erstellt.
Wie auch das BKA.
Und in Deutschland ist ja auch in der Diskussion, dass es das BKA machen soll. Und die sagen ja auch, sie hätten schon eine Liste mit über 1000 Einträgen.
So, jetzt ist von Familienministerium und aber auch von den Behörden vom BKA heißt es immer, okay, da ist diese Pornografie, Kinderpornografie im Netz und wir kriegen die da nicht raus. So und jetzt, was machen wir? Wir kommen an diese Anbieter irgendwie nicht ran. Deswegen sperren wir das jetzt, weil das ist irgendwie das allerletzte Mittel, sagt auch die Frau von der Leyen. Es ist alles nicht schön, das wissen wir, aber wir wollen diesen Mist aus dem Netz haben. Wir wollen ihn nicht mehr sehen und wir wollen nicht mehr, dass die Leute da rankommen. Zumindest wollen wir es den Leuten, die da rankommen, wollen unbedingt ganz doll schwierig machen. Wir haben jetzt aber auch schon in der Sendung bisher gehört, das war eigentlich auch so, würde ich mal sagen, Condensed, dass alle gesagt haben, naja, also das Sperren, wegfiltern, das löst das Problem nicht wirklich. Sondern man müsste dann irgendwie Leute rangehen. Man sollte direkt auch in die Server ran und sollte schauen, dass man deren habhaft wird. Also nicht nur dem Server, sondern möglichst auch den Leuten, die die betreiben und die Kinderpornografie da vertreiben, verkaufen und damit möglicherweise sogar Geld verdienen. BKA ist wahrscheinlich dafür bei uns zuständig, wenn es um Sachen geht, die im Ausland stehen. Da gibt es eigentlich festgelegte Wege. Aber die Frage ist jetzt, ob die tatsächlich diese Wege auch beschritten werden. Also das heißt jetzt erstmal, ok, da ist eine Liste und die wollen wir jetzt sperren, weil wir kommen da nicht ran, wir kommen an dieses Server nicht ran. Wo stehen denn diese Server eigentlich? Oder was hast du jetzt gemacht, um herauszufinden, wo diese Server eigentlich stehen?
Naja, was ich gemacht hab, ist, ich hab mir im Internet Listen gesucht aus unseren europäischen Nachbarländern, die das schon machen, die mal veröffentlicht wurden, die von Aktivisten per Versuch, try and error, herausgefunden wurden. Also das Ding ist, sie sagen ja, sie wollen die Listen nicht veröffentlichen. Weil das wäre ja Werbung für die Seite. Aber man muss feststellen, dass wenn sie DNS-Sperren machen, dann veröffentlichen sie die Liste in dem Moment, wo sie die Sperren aktivieren. Das ist ähnlich wie beim Informationsfreiheitsgesetz. Das Problem ist dann, man muss die richtigen Fragen stellen. Nämlich nach den richtigen Domainsfragen und mal klären, ob die IP-Adresse, die man als Antwort kriegt, noch die richtige ist.
Das heißt also, wenn ich nicht weiß, welche Seiten gesperrt sind, probiere ich einfach alle durch und die Seiten, die dann nicht wie erwartet ist anzeigen, sind möglicherweise gesperrt.
Ja, da kann man ja dann mal draufgehen auf die IP-Adresse, die man kriegt. Und wenn dann wie in Schweden so eine schöne Stoppseite von der Polizei kommt mit dem Hinweis, dass das illegal ist und so, dann hat man eine gesperrte Seite gefunden. Das heißt, man muss immer nur die richtigen Fragen stellen, aber die Listen müssen sie veröffentlichen, sonst können sie die Filter nicht implementieren. Zumindest auf DNS-Ebene ist das so.
Sind die DNS-Filter, von denen Andreas vorhin schon mal sprach?
Genau. Und ich habe jetzt mir Listen gesucht, die veröffentlicht wurden auf Wikileaks, haben Leute Listen veröffentlicht oder sind welche geleakt? Aus Dänemark glaube ich und aus Thailand. Es gibt Aktivisten in Schweden und in Finnland, die sich einen Spaß daraus gemacht haben, eben die richtigen Fragen an den DNS-Server zu stellen und solche Listen rauszufinden, einfach durchprobieren. Und genau die habe ich mir genommen, die man halt so findet. Und habe die einfach mal durch einen Perl-Script laufen lassen, was die Geolokationen der IP-Nummern rausfindet, auf welche diese Einträge zeigen.
Also sprich, wo sie stehen.
Ja genau, wo stehen die Server? Naja, und die Server stehen halt zum größten Teil in Juristikationen, in denen eine Verfolgung durchaus möglich wäre.
Ohne eine Wegsperrung der Seiten, sondern es ist anders, auf einem Weg möglich.
Naja klar, wenn so ein Server in den Niederlanden steht, ich meine das ist kein Problem. Wenn man bei den Niederländern anruft und sagt, hier Kinderpauno, die Adresse, der und der Server, steht bei euch, das ist der und der Anbieter, ich meine, dann geht's los, dann kriegen die da rapzap irgendwie einen Beschluss und fahren da hin und holen sich den Server zur forensischen Analyse. Also das wär zumindest, ja, so erstmal kein weiteres Problem. Und in Großbritannien, in Frankreich, in Spanien, in den USA, ich weiß nicht, ist das doch überall so? Ich meine, bei Kinderpauno sind sie sich doch einig, da klappt das doch mit der Rechtshilfe relativ gut.
Was ist so die Top 3 der Länder?
Ja, die Top 3 ist USA, Australien, Niederlande und auf Platz 4 Deutschland.
Es ist ja auch tatsächlich so, dass das passiert. Es gibt Kooperationen der Provider untereinander, das In-Hope-Projekt, die Strafverfolgern zuarbeiten. Also ich hab auch mal diese Listen angeguckt, also insbesondere die aus Dänemark, die auf Wikileaks auch getaucht sind. Und vieles davon existiert einfach nicht mehr und das existiert ja mit einem bestimmten Grund nicht mehr, eben weil diese Strafverfolgung auch ein Stück weit funktioniert und diese Server werden beschlagnahmt.
Ja, aber wenn man, also das ist wahrscheinlich auch so, also ich hab die Liste dann auch nochmal bereinigt und Sachen, die geparkt sind und Sachen, die nicht auflösbar sind und so was rausgenommen. Also Dinge, die es nicht mehr gibt, dann bleiben auch nur noch 1500 Einträge von ursprünglich 6000 irgendwas übrig. Von ursprünglich 6021 bleiben da noch 1413. Und wenn man die nochmal durchjagt, na dann sind die Zahlen halt geringer, aber das Bild ist nicht ein anderes. Also die USA führen immer noch, gefolgt von Australien, gefolgt von Kanada. Niederlande auf Platz 4, Deutschland auf Platz 5.
Okay, aber welchen Schluss ziehen wir jetzt denn daraus, wenn es doch so relativ einfach ist, rauszukriegen, wo die Server stehen und dann mit den jetzt schon vorhandenen Mitteln der Strafverfolgung das anzugehen?
Ja, mein Schluss daraus ist ähnlich wie von Nicky aus Finnland, der auch sowas macht, der sich auch die Seiten zum Teil mal angeguckt hat und der halt wirklich Kinderpornografie mit unter 1% in den Adresslisten gefunden hat. Also es ist davon auszugehen oder es sieht so aus, dass auch in anderen Ländern eben nicht nur Kinderpornoseiten gesperrt werden, sondern die sind da relativ großzügig. Also eine Seite, die auf eine Kinderpornoseite linkt, wird auch mitgesperrt. Das sagen sie ja auch. Aber es sind halt auch viele Seiten dabei. Das ist halt Schwulenporn oder ich weiß nicht, sonst irgendwas, aber nichts, was jetzt wirklich illegal ist. Das einzigste, was die Seiten nicht machen, ist, sie haben nicht so eine Zugangssperre, wie es in Deutschland zum Beispiel vorgeschrieben ist, dass man halt da nur rankommt, wenn man 18 ist. Und das auch beweisen kann.
Würdest du so weit gehen zu sagen, dass dieses Gesetz, was jetzt möglicherweise in Kraft oder was jetzt diskutiert wird, dass das ein Schritt zur Zensur im Netz wird und liegt zur Nichtverfügungmachung von Inhalten?
Also es ist auf jeden Fall der Aufbau einer Zensurinfrastruktur, die einem diese Möglichkeiten bietet, Sachen zu unterbinden. Also ich meine, die Polizei ist sehr schlecht ausgestattet, klagt sie auch selber immer drüber. Und sie sagen ja auch, sie haben nicht genug Internetermittler und sie sind nicht kompetent genug, sie haben noch nicht mal genug Computer und so weiter und so fort. Und ich meine, das braucht man halt, wenn man da hinterher gehen will. Insofern ist das dann einfacher, weil das kann man einfach in eine Liste eintragen und dann ist gut.
Und dann gibt es nicht mehr alles weg.
Und da ist natürlich die Versuchung groß, irgendwie es auf die einfache Art und Weise zu lösen. Die Gefahr sehe ich zum einen. Die andere Gefahr, die ich sehe, ist, dass sie aufgrund von Personalmangel und sonst wie mangelnder technischer Kompetenz die Sachen automatisieren oder versuchen sie zu automatisieren.
Das Spannende ist ja auch die Stelle, an der gefiltert wird. Also einer der Grundsätze, die im CCC ab und zu mal wieder in den Mund genommen werden, ist, dass die Filterung findet im Endgerät statt. Also was mich besonders bedenklich gestimmt hat, ist eben, dass diese Zensurlisten nicht verfügbar gemacht werden zu Jugendschutzzwecken. Dass man eben sagen kann, wenn Eltern Sorge haben, dass die Kinder irgendwie im Internet komische Dinge sehen, dass man dann sich dieser Listen bedienen kann, sondern dass das quasi vom User unbeeinflussbar schon beim Internet Service Provider geschehen soll.
Und Programme, mit denen quasi Eltern den Rechner, also den heimatlichen Rechner, so bauen bzw. filtern können, dass ihre Sprösslinge nicht an bestimmte Webseiten rankommen. Da gibt es mehr als genug, zum Beispiel eine Menge sogar kostenlos. Fragtim, glaube ich, heißt eine. Das ist wo man irgendwie angeben kann, welche Webseiten es gibt. Also da gibt es eine ganze Menge und damit sind wir auch wieder bei der ganzen Verhältnismäßigkeit dieser Geschichte, die Alba vorher noch angesprochen hat.
Wobei es gibt ja immer noch diesen ganz komischen Ansatz, dass man sagt, alle Leute müssen sich auf ihrem PC eine Software installieren, die dann die Sachen wegfiltert.
Ja und porno im Internet erst nach 23 Uhr die Idee fand ich eigentlich nicht. Weil irgendwo auf der Welt ist es immer 23 Uhr. Und geht es dann nach, wo der Server steht oder wo der Client steht? Oder nimmt man ja...
Aber dann strich dir das alles nicht von der Grundannahme eines mündigen Bürgers aus, sondern davon, dass der Bürger vor irgendwas geschützt werden muss.
Um darauf zurückzukommen, ich sehe da noch weitere Probleme mit solchen Listen. In Finnland ist es zum Beispiel passiert, dass genau die Webseite, die diese Listen veröffentlicht hat, also wo der Aktivist da seine Sachen gepostet hat, dass die auch auf die Sperrliste gekommen ist. Also man hat dann die Leute, die die Zensur dokumentieren, auch gleich mit zensiert. Das war ihnen ein bisschen peinlich, das haben sie dann nach einer Woche auch wieder rückgängig gemacht, nachdem in der Zeitung zu lesen war, Polizei zensiert Zensurkritiker. Aber es zeigt, wo es hingehen kann. Und genau wenn man nicht genügend Ressourcen hat, ist die Versuchung natürlich groß für die Behörden, das zu automatisieren und sich darauf zu verlassen, was der Hersteller gesagt hat.
Womit wir zwei Sachen angesprochen hätten, die wichtig sind und die auch noch zu diskutieren sind. Zum einen natürlich, wer kontrolliert die Zensur? Also wer ist dafür zuständig, was das für Listen sind? Und zum zweiten, das was Nübler eben auch angesprochen hat, die Filterung findet im Endgerät statt. Also dass unterm Strich jeder User, jeder Internetbenutzer sein eigener Filter ist und selbst quasi die Hoheit der demokratischen Entscheidung hat zu sagen, das will ich im Netz sehen und das will ich im Netz nicht sehen und das gucke ich mir nicht an. Und sollte der Rechner von mehreren Leuten benutzt werden, da auch ein Mitspracherecht hat.
Die Freiheit und Möglichkeit hat ja jeder heutzutage schon und viele Leute benden sich ja Werbeanzeigen auch aus auf ihren Internetseiten oder in ihren Browsern.
Genau, dazu fragen wir gleich mal jemanden, der junger Vater ist, der mehrere Kinder auch zu Hause hat. Florian, ich wollte noch ganz kurz die Adresse von deinem Blog sagen. Damit die Leute auch noch mal nachlesen können. Das ist scusi.blog.org, scusi mit C. Und da ist das alles noch mal nachzulesen jetzt, Frank.
Entschuldigung, nee, auch noch mal ganz kurz dein Fazit sozusagen. Also wenn aus der Politik behauptet wird, wir kommen an diese Server nicht ran, kannst du sagen, Quatsch, also ich hab hier die Zahlen, wäre alles möglich, zumindestens in einer Großzahl der Fälle.
Naja, mein Problem ist, ich hab die ja im Prinzip ja, aber ich hab keine aktuellen Listen. Und wenn man mir die aktuelle Liste gibt, kann ich das auf jeden Fall. Aber ich unterschreib keinen NDA dafür. Und ansonsten werde ich, sobald diese Listen aktiv sind, versuchen sie rauszufinden. Und da bin ich guter Dinge, dass ich das schaffe und dann werde ich sie auch posten. Ich meine, ich habe ja nur die richtigen Fragen gestellt.
Aber das wäre jetzt auch eine ganz klare Forderung an die Politik, zu sagen, du weißt erst mal, dass ihr wirklich versucht habt, an diese Dinge heranzukommen.
Man tut erst mal alles Mögliche, was man technisch, menschlich, kriminalistisch, forensisch, weiß ich nicht, tun kann, um an die Hintermänner heranzukommen. Folgt den Finanzströmen irgendwie. Also zieht die Leute aus dem Verkehr, die das Zeug herstellen und die daran verdienen. Und die Seiten auszublenden ist keine Lösung. Und das schützt auch kein Kind vor irgendeinem Missbrauch. Ein Kind vor Missbrauch schützen, wie die Frau Leiden vorgibt, zu tun, kann sie erst, wenn sie wirklich so einen Typen einsperrt, der sowas gemacht hat und wo die Chance, dass er es wieder macht, irgendwie gegeben ist.
Sagt Florian Walter von scusiblog.org. Danke dir Florian. Oh, da war ein radikaler Hörer aufgeschmissen.
Das war jetzt alles okay. Einen Einwurf habe ich aber noch an der Stelle. Und zwar, Wegsperren hilft nicht nur, weil das hilft erst, wenn es schon zu spät ist, wenn der Missbrauch schon passiert ist. Therapie hilft. Und es gibt in Berlin ein einzigartiges Pilotprojekt in Deutschland. Eine Therapiestelle für Pädophile. Also Leute, die das Problem haben, so ey Scheiße, ich stehe auf Kinder. Was mache ich denn jetzt? Hingehen können, sich damit beschäftigen können und irgendwie da Lösungen angeboten bekommen. Und ich denke, das ist viel, viel hilfreicher als irgendwelche Filter, irgendwelche Sperrlisten tatsächlich Missbrauch zu verhindern.
Und die sind da auch sehr unverkrampft auf die Leute mit diesen Problemen zugegangen. Mit Pustern, auf denen eben die Frage gestellt wurde, mögen sie Kinder mehr als ihnen lieb ist. Also es ist ja wahrscheinlich das erste Mal, dass jemand, der mit diesen Problemen konfrontiert wird, nicht sich dafür vor der Gesellschaft irgendwie schämen und in die Ecke und überhaupt, sondern ihm geholfen wird, damit in irgendeiner Form umzugehen, wie es für die Gesellschaft nicht zum Problem wird.
Chaosradio auf Fritz, Nummer 142 mittlerweile schon. Es geht um Zensur am Internet, die angedacht wird vom Bundesfamilienministerium. Und wir haben Chris am Telefon. Guten Abend Chris, grüß dich. Hast du gehört, was Frank eben gerade alles erzählt hat? Was ist denn deine Meinung dazu?
Ja, wie gesagt, also dieses Wagnungs von der Charité sogar wurde zu kurz ausgestrahlt, man sollte einfach mehr dahinter sein. Und die Politik sollte einfach mal, oder die Justiz und Politik, also die Justiz von der Politik sollte einfach mehr, ja, sollten mehr Strafen, die sollten einfach mehr Gesetze dafür rausbringen. Und gerade sich damit mehr befassen. Die reden alle von wegen, ja, Kinderschutzbund und sonstiges, aber irgendwie bleibt das auf der Strecke.
Aber du meinst jetzt, du willst mehr Gesetze machen. Das heißt, du meinst, die Gesetze, die wir jetzt haben, reichen nicht aus?
Die sollten verschärft werden. Das reicht nicht aus. Kein Fall. Und das stimmt schon. Also hier irgendwelche Dinge zu spüren, hilft auch nicht. Ich mein, der Missbrauch bleibt trotzdem. Ich find's sowieso krass. Also ich bin wie gesagt Vater. Und wenn ich daran denke, dann wird mir schlecht.
Wie ist das bei euch zu Hause? Wenn du sagst, du bist Vater, hast also auch Kinder, gibt es da so feste Regeln, wonach du sagst, hier an dem Rechner werden nur von dann und dann im Netz gesurft?
Also ich hab meinen PC so eingerichtet, dass er gar nicht auf andere Seiten kommen kann.
Bei dem CCT-Grundsatz, den Nibbler eben vorhin sagte, der letzte Filter oder eigentliche Filter sitzt immer noch davor. Aber was hältst du von der Verhältnismäßigkeit, die geplant wurde, also Webseiten wegzusperren?
Wenn sie es auch machen, also reden bringt nichts.
Das Gesetz ist jetzt in der Diskussion. Es soll, wenn ich das richtig mitgekriegt habe, irgendwie im Laufe dieses Jahres in der Änderung vom Medien... Andreas, hilf mir mal. Das Gesetz heißt das Medien... Telemediengesetz. Da soll es eine Änderung geben dieses Jahr. Da wird noch einiges passieren. Wir haben ja auch Wahljahr. Wahrscheinlich wird sich da noch einiges tun. Aber danke dir erstmal für den Anruf, Chris. 0331 70 97 110 Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir reden über den Vorstoß vom Bundesfamilienministerium von Frau von der Leyen, die sich Anfang des Monats mit deutschen Provider getroffen hat, mit verschiedenen, um bestimmte Webseiten wegzusperren. Wir versuchen zu klären, wie das technisch eigentlich funktioniert und sind immer noch bei der bislang ungeklärten Frage, dass es eigentlich keine sowohl juristische als auch moralische Grundstruktur gibt, wonach diese Sperrung und Filterung eigentlich passieren kann. Es wurde immer der Vorschuss gemacht, wir müssen das alles verbieten, aber keiner weiß auf welcher Grundlage sowas passieren soll, Frank.
Das ist ja auch so ein bisschen schwierig, weil man muss das dann mal ein bisschen aufrollen oder nach hinten weiterspinnen, je nachdem von welcher Seite man es betrachtet. Wenn ich jetzt Internet-User bin, ich habe einen Vertrag mit meinem Internetprovider, und dieser Internetprovider zeigt mir jetzt bestimmte Sachen nicht an. Das heißt also, aus meiner Sicht erbringt er dann erstmal eine bestimmte Dienstleistung nicht ordnungsgemäß. Dann muss ich ja auch eine Möglichkeit haben als Kunde zu sagen, bitte lieber Internetprovider, du erbringst ja deine Dienstleistung nicht richtig. Dann muss der Provider natürlich sagen, ja aber ich mach das doch, weil ich bin zum Beispiel per Gesetz verpflichtet diese Seiten rauszufiltern. Oder so wie es jetzt im Moment ist, steht der Internetprovider relativ blöd da. Und kann halt wissen sagen, hey du Ferkel, du wolltest hier Kinderpornografie klicken, gibt es bei uns nicht, geh zu einem anderen Provider. Oder er sagt halt, naja, wir haben da mit der Ministerin mal irgendwie einen Tee getrunken und die hat uns eine Liste gegeben und die sperren wir jetzt. Das ist die Situation, die wir jetzt haben. Und die ist natürlich für einen Internetprovider auch nicht wirklich zufriedenstellend. Weil er weiß ja oder müsste eigentlich diese Liste immer kontrollieren und dann nochmal pro Eintrag, der da drauf ist, schauen, ob er das dann wirklich auch sperren will. Und müsste sich der Sache eigentlich auch wieder setzen. Und das ist natürlich dann auch wieder eine schwierige Situation, wenn jetzt der Provider anfangen muss, nochmal wirklich diese Liste zu prüfen, ob denn da wirklich auch tatsächlich echt strafbare Inhalte drin sind.
Das ist natürlich auch eine PR-Frage. Also gerade das Thema Kinderpornos sehr emotional beladen. Und als ISP, das große ISP, wenn man dann auch nicht dastehen und sich von der Familienministerin sagen lassen, ja, alle haben mitgemacht, aber die Bude da nicht, das sind ganz böse Leute und die verbreiten Verbreitung von Kinderpornos. Da ist natürlich auch bei den ISPs so ein bisschen die Angst, dass dann damit der Keule gekommen wird.
Ja, andererseits ist es so, wenn dann auch möglicherweise mehr Sachen gesperrt werden. Also ich meine, es ist natürlich auch ein bisschen negatives Marketingargument, wenn man sagt, naja, bei dem Provider kann man kein Porno klicken. Also könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass das durchaus auch eine gewisse Anzahl von Kunden abschreckt.
Oder um einfach mal jetzt auch von dieser Porno-Kiste wegzukommen, da kann man halt keine Musik aus dem Netz laden. Du kannst keine Musik aus dem Netz laden, oder? Aber was es in Hessen gab, den Vorschlag aus Hessen, der im letzten Dezember, also letzten Monat kam, dass die sagten, so internationale Lotterie-Seiten, die es im Netz gibt, die hätten wir gerne auch nicht mehr. Und vielleicht können die auch gleich mit weggeschaltet werden.
Dann Chemikalienversand wird weggefiltert. Kommst du vom 100.
ins 1000. Und da diese Listen nicht öffentlich sind, da diese Listen nicht einsehbar sind und bislang immer noch nicht klar ist, wer quasi die Zensoren kontrolliert, was da passiert, wird dann eine Büchse der Pandora aufgemacht, von der keiner weiß, was da im Endeffekt wirklich das Resultat ist, was dabei rauskommt.
So ein schönes Argument, was man von Internetausdruckern hört, das Internet ist kein rechtsfreier Raum.
Der Internetausdrucker ist toll.
Wer behauptet, dass das Internet kein rechtsfreier Raum ist, hat noch nicht verstanden, dass das Internet gar kein Raum ist.
Sondern?
Das war jetzt auch ein schönes Gegenargument. Da musst du noch ein bisschen weiter argumentieren, Snibbler.
Es ist ein Netz.
Sachen sind nur dann im Internet illegal, wenn sie ohne Internet auch illegal sind.
Musik.
In dem so ist, dann ist es okay, Musik. Chaosradio auf Ritz, Teil 142 am 28. Januar 2009. Wir reden über Zensur im Internet, das Internet soll sauber werden, ein Familieninternet werden gefiltert mit verbotenen Inhalten, also mit Inhalten, die verboten werden und zensiert. Eure Meinung dazu unter 0331 70 97 110. Der nächste am Telefon ist Sattarj aus Berlin. Guten Abend Sattarj, grüß dich. Was hältst du denn von dieser angedachten Zensur von bestimmten Webseiten, von der keiner noch so richtig weiß, a. auf welcher rechtlichen Grundlage es steht und b. wo es hinführt?
Also, ich finde es schon mal gut, dass man sich darüber erstmal einen Kopf macht, wie man das wegkriegt. Aber die Seiten einfach filtern bringt nicht wirklich viel, weil erstens würden die nie im Leben, würde der Staat oder die, die das machen, würden nie neben alle Seiten rausfinden. Das heißt, irgendwo gibt es immer die Seiten. Und die Leute einfach, wenn man die Seiten einfach sperrt, würde man sich einfach neu schaffen, wo der auch schon gesagt, und was jetzt auch das Problem ist, die Leute, also die Menschen sind einfach so, wenn irgendwas nicht gesättigt ist, gibt es denen halt, also die meisten, halt einen Kick sozusagen. Also, dass sie das halt weitermachen, dass es denen halt mehr Spaß macht, wobei es halt nämlich gesättigt ist. Und damit kann man sich nicht wirklich verhindern. Also so wird es einfach mit den Seiten filtern.
Also da muss ich jetzt mal die, mal eine Argumentation vom Ministerium anbringen. Dass sie sagen, ja, also wenn die Anbieter sich dann aber eine neue Adresse suchen, dann sind sie ja auch erstmal nicht auffindbar, so ohne Freiheit. Also dann sind sie quasi erstmal, dann ist die übliche Quelle ist dann weg. Ich muss mir denn wieder was Neues suchen. Und damit ist möglicherweise schon ein Ziel auch wieder erreicht.
Hält einen aber nicht davon auf, davon ab, diese URL per E-Mail oder auf irgendeinem anderen Weg zu distributen?
Klar, man muss es dann aber erstmal wieder bekommen. Aber ich sag mal, der übliche, also das ist halt so, als wenn mein Zeitungsladen an der Ecke zumacht, so dann muss ich mir halt erstmal einen anderen suchen. Zumindest für ein paar Tage habe ich dann möglicherweise keine Zeitung zu Hause.
Die Argumentation an sich ist klar und auch logisch, je höher du die Hürde legst, um irgendwas ranzukommen, desto schwieriger wird es, dass Leute das finden. Soweit so gut und soweit auch so richtig. Aber die Gefahren bzw. die Abas und die ungeklärten Punkte, die da hinten dranhängen, die tauchen eben nicht in dieser Argumentation auf. Die zum Beispiel beinhalten, was ist, wenn es andere Befindlichkeiten gibt von Leuten, die sagen, wir hätten sowas gerne nicht mehr im Netz, wie Musikindustrie, wie Lottogesellschaften und sonst was. Das ist ja alles noch nicht geklärt.
Ja, also ich bin auch konkret gegen Pornografie. Und wenn du kurzestern kurz aus der Wohnung raus... Ich muss leise sein, die schlafen alle. Da hat mich ein langer Moment.
Ja, wir wollen ja keinen wecken. Wobei, wenn ihr jetzt hier einschlaft, verpasst ihr noch eine Menge.
Aber sag mal ganz kurz, du hast gesagt, gegen Pornografie, meinst du jetzt gegen Kinder, also Missbrauchsdarstellung von Kindern? Oder generell gegen Pornografie?
Also gegen Pornografie, jetzt allgemein habe ich ein Geschenk, also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel so was macht, so gegen Kinderpornografie. Dagegen bin ich total, ich habe selber ein Kind, das jetzt zwei Jahre alt ist. Wenn mein Kind später aus seinen Seiten gehen würde, ich weiß nicht, auf was für Gedanken er kommen würde. Ich würde das für mein Kind einfach nicht anfinden. Bei mir hat zum Beispiel mein Rechner, auch wenn wir ganz oft bekannte, und ich schlafe auch ganz viel mit den Kindern da. Wir haben fünf Computer zu Hause. Ich habe mir selber am Programm geschrieben. Wo der kontrolliert, was für Seiten sind, und wenn das eine pornografische Seite ist, wird sie sofort gesperrt. Also, dass schon gar nichts mehr drauf kann. Und wenn es halt eine porno-Date ist...
Von welchen Kriterien?
Wie von welchen Kriterien?
Na, wie stellt deine Software fest, das ist porno oder das ist kein porno?
Na, in dem Moment, wenn man auf so eine Seite rausgeht, kriegt man ja auch Videos an, normalerweise. Also man ist ja nicht so da, um die Bilder, sich von den Videos anzugucken, die Startbilder. Und in dem Moment merkt man ja, merkt meine Software, mein Programm, dass es ein porno-Set ist und sperrt die dann halt sofort. Weil ich nicht will, dass Kinder so was schon in so einem Jahr mitkriegen.
Womit wir bei der Anfangsdiskussion sind, dass im Endeffekt auch die Eltern bzw. die Leute, die mit Kindern zusammenleben, größere Geschwister, wer auch immer, dafür auch in die Verantwortung zu nehmen sind, mitzugucken, was da im Netz und auf dem Rechner zu sehen ist oder nicht. Danke für deine Aufmerksamkeit, wir müssen jetzt die Nachrichten machen. Ja, schönen Abend und wieder leise in die Wohnung, sonst wächst ihr alle auf.
Na, Deutschlands größter Musikpreis?
Jetzt präsentiert, Echo, Echo, Valhalla, Echo 2009, live in Berlin und im ersten, mit Amy McDonald, Katy Perry, you too und vielen, vielen, vielen mehr. Samstag, 21. Februar in der Echo Two World Berlin.
Natürlich im Fritz-Echo-Radio.
Die Echo-Verleihung 2009 in Berlin. Live im ersten deutschen Fernsehen.
Und im letzten deutschen Radio.
Und das war's. Nachrichten.
Mit Kaitern Dürlich.
Der Vorsitzende des Landeselternausschüsse Schindler fordert zusätzliche Anreize für Nachwuchslehrer. Damit sollen angehende Lehrer an den Berliner Schulen gehalten werden. Berlin müsse die jungen Pädagogen besser vergüten, sagte Schindler. Er ist aber gegen eine generelle Verbeamtung von Lehrern. Mehr als 100 junge Pädagogen hatten zuvor angekündigt, sich in anderen Bundesländern zu bewerben. Dort würden sie besser bezahlt werden und die Chance haben, verbeamtet zu werden. Wer morgen mit dem Zug fahren will, sollte sich auf Behinderung einstellen. In insgesamt neun Städten wollen morgen früh Bahnmitarbeiter streiken. Auch Berlin ist davon betroffen. S- und U-Bahn sowie Busse werden aber normal fahren. Die Gewerkschaften Transnet und GDBA haben angekündigt, dass bis in den späten Vormittag hineingestreikt werden soll und dass deswegen Züge zu spät kommen oder sogar ausfallen werden. Mit dem Streik soll Druck im Tarifstreit gemacht werden, bei dem es laut den Gewerkschaften nicht vorangeht. Im Zeichen der internationalen Finanz- und Wirtschaftskrise hat in Davos das Weltwirtschaftsforum begonnen. Bei der Eröffnung warnte der russische Minister Präsident Putin vor zu starken Eingriffen des Staates in die Wirtschaft. Dabei hat er auf Erfahrung in der Sowjetunion hingewiesen. Bis zum Sonntag tauschen sich beim Weltwirtschaftsforum 2500 Persönlichkeiten aus Politik und Wirtschaft über die aktuellen Entwicklungen aus. Energie Cottbus ist im Achtelfinale des DFB Pokals ausgeschieden. Cottbus unterlag Leverkusen mit 1 zu 3. Außerdem spielten Dortmund Bremen 1 zu 2, Wolfsburg Rostock 5 zu 1 und Karlsruhe Wien Wiesbaden 0 zu 1. Überschattet wurde das Achtelfinale von einem tragischen Zwischenfall in Dortmund. Ein Fan stürzte kurz vor dem Spiel von der Südtribüne und erlitt tödliche Verletzungen. Die Ursache für den Sturz sind bisher noch nicht geklärt. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen in Cottbus, Frankfurt, Neurupien, Wittenberge und Angermünde da haben wir minus 4 Grad, Potsdam minus 3 und in Berlin da haben wir zwischen minus 3 und minus 4 Grad. In dieser Nacht geht es mit den Temperaturen immer weiter runter mit Tieswerten zwischen minus 1 und minus 5 Grad. Dazu haben wir viel Nebel und auch der Rest der Woche bleibt nebelig und trüb. Nachts bleibt es meist frostig, tagsüber wird es aber meistens trocken bleiben. Morgen haben wir dann Temperaturen von maximal plus 2 Grad. Wir haben eine Meldung aus Brandenburg auf der A115 Abus Zubringer Nutetal statt auswärts zwischen Kreuz Zehlendorf und Kleinmachno. Da befinden sich Wildschweine auf der Fahrbahn. Fahr dort bitte besonders vorsichtig, ansonsten eine gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB. Und wenn im Radio 101, 5?
Dann Fritz in Frankfurt Oder.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Da war das Mikro noch offen, aber das heißt wir sind auch da. Chaosradio 142 auf Fritz. Frage ist hier, Nibbler ist da, Andreas ist da, mein Name ist Jakob Kranz, Chaos Computer Club begrüßt euch. Wir diskutieren über die angesetzte und angeplante Zensur und Filterung im Internet, die von der Bundesfamilienministerin Frau von der Leyen ja im Moment angeschoben wird. Wir hatten vorhin ganz kurz das Thema Filter gestreift, eben gerade als Zertasch auch nochmal gesagt, dass der Rechner bei ihm zu Hause auch mit einer Art Filter funktioniert, woraufhin Nibbler mehr oder weniger noch dazwischen ging und sagte, ja so genau kann der Filter gar nicht gehen. Das müssen wir jetzt nochmal in Ruhe klären. Also wir hatten vorhin die DNS-Filter, die in skandinavischen Ländern funktionieren, die aber nicht die Filter sind, die hier eingesetzt werden sollen, oder?
Ja, da ist ein bisschen unklar, was wir als Filter einsetzen, aber ich gehe mal von aus, dass das nicht bei DNS-Filtern bleiben wird, weil inzwischen, glaube ich, dithinreichend bekannt sein dürfte, wie man das Ganze umgeht und anderen DNS-Server eintragen und weitersurfen. Ich kann mir durchaus vorstellen, dass das anspruchsvoller wird.
Also ist dieses DNS-Filtersystem überhaupt keine Option für hier?
Also nochmal ganz kurz, DNS, also Domain Name Service, dafür steht hier Abkürzung, ist also der Dienst im Internet, der den Namen von der Webseite in die numerische IP-Adresse, also die eigentliche Internetadresse umwandelt. Und was bei dieser DNS-Sperre gemacht wird, ist, dass dieser Name dann nicht zu der richtigen IP-Adresse aufgelöst wird, sondern zu einer anderen oder gar nicht aufgelöst wird. Und damit wird also sozusagen nicht die eigentliche Verbindung zu der Webseite gekappt, sondern sie wird nur nicht richtig gefunden.
Das heißt, wer du weißt, wo du suchen musst, findest du es trotzdem?
Genau, wenn man sich also schafft, den Weg, diese IP-Adresse von der eigentlichen Webseite zu besorgen, indem man zum Beispiel einfach nicht den DNS-Server, also diesen Namensauflösungsdienst fragt, den mir mein Provider anbietet, sondern ich mir einen eigenen baue, das geht ja. Es gibt also die großen, diese sogenannten Root-Server, die im Internet stehen, die also eine Datenbank haben von allen, die so die Autorität sind des Netzes. Mein Internet-Provider, der bietet mir diesen DNS an, diesen Server, den ich dann anfrage. Der macht das einfach, damit nicht jeder kleine Popelrechner irgendwie diese großen Root-Nameserver, die im Internet irgendwo stehen, anfragt, sondern das ist wie so ein Proxy, also ein Stellvertreter. Das heißt also, ich frag den an und der fragt dann, wenn das nicht eh schon weiß, die IP-Adresse, dann den nächstgelegenen an. Und was ich dann einfach mache, wenn ich so eine DNS-Sperre umgehen will, ist, dass ich mir einfach irgendeinen anderen DNS-Server suche, der diese Sperre nicht eingebaut hat, der kann irgendwo in einem anderen Land stehen. Das kann aber auch ein eigener sein, den ich mir irgendwie gesucht hab oder der von irgendjemand anders betrieben wird.
Und wie soll das jetzt rein technisch funktionieren, mit diesen Filtern, die angedacht werden?
Also was ich mir zum Beispiel vorstellen könnte... Da müssen wir mal kurz einen Exkurs machen, wie dieses Internet eigentlich zusammenhängt. Die Provider sprechen untereinander das Border Gateway Protocol, also BGP. Das ist ein Protokoll, mit dem ausgetauscht wird, welche IP-Adressen sich wo befinden. Also ich krieg von meinem Internetprovider beispielsweise als Internet... Also wenn ich selbst einen Internetprovider bin und mit anderen Traffic austausche, bekomme ich jeweils den Satz IP-Adressen, die Netze, die hinter dem Provider liegen und kann dann selbst entscheiden, was sich in welche Richtung rute. Ja, so ist das Internet quasi als Flickenteppich zusammengeklebt. Jeder tauscht mit jedem auf einer bestimmten Basis seine Routen aus. Und da, schätze ich mal, werden sie ansetzen, dass man also nicht ganze Netze jetzt filtert und austauscht. Sondern, dass man einzelne IP-Adressen hat, die in irgendeiner Form bösen Content enthalten. Und die quasi beim Internet-Service-Provider aus dem Routing nimmt, über einen Proxy leitet, URLs ausfiltert und das Ganze weitergibt. Je nachdem, wie viel Traffic man hat, ist das dann entweder ein Proxy oder eine kompliziertere Filter-Einrichtung, die speziell sich Pakete anguckt, ansonsten alles vorwortet. Aber wenn eine bestimmte URL drin vorkommt, die Verbindung zurücksetzt oder anderen Content einbaut, das ist mittlerweile technisch quasi problemlos möglich.
Ganz kurz gefragt, also ich kenne natürlich die Antwort, aber nochmal für die Hörer, warum sperrt man nicht eine einzelne IP-Adresse einfach?
Weil auf einer IP-Adresse, Beispiel Geocities oder irgendwelche Free-Hoster, wo man auf einem Server ganz viele Websites liegen hat, wenn man da eine einzelne IP sperren würde, gäbe das einfach zu viel Kollateralschaden.
Das heißt, du sperrst eine IP-Adresse und haust alle anderen gleich mit weg?
Ja, und das ist natürlich etwas, was den Usern auch nicht gefällt. Den Usern ist es wahrscheinlich ziemlich egal, ob da jetzt Kinder-Porno gefiltert wird oder nicht. Aber wenn noch mehr nicht geht, dann fällt das zum einen rüber auf und zum anderen geht es am Ziel vorbei.
Aber wäre das nicht ein Druckmittel gegen den Serverbetreiber? Wenn du irgendwo auf deinem Server Kinder-Pornografie hast, entsperren wir dir einfach den Server?
Ja, aber das geht viel zu sehr wieder in Richtung Strafverfolgung. Und das ist ja scheinbar das, was gerade nicht hip ist. Also wenn es um Strafverfolgung ginge, würden sie ja gleich zu den Serverbetreibern hingehen und die unter Druck setzen. Das scheint ja wohl nicht so das Problem zu sein.
Weil, wie wir vorhin gehört haben, ist es relativ einfach nachzuvollziehen, wo die Server stehen.
Das passiert ja auch schon. Also wenn tatsächlich Serverbetreiber verhaftet, die sollte es Material anbieten. Es gibt Server, die sind nicht mehr da, einfach aus genau diesem Grund.
Okay, also wir fassen nochmal ganz kurz zusammen. Die Server sind relativ einfach zu finden, mit normalen Mitteln der Strafverfolgung. Das heißt, du kannst die Leute auch an Arsch kriegen, wenn du das denn möchtest. Und jetzt kommt Robert ins Spiel. Robert hat angerufen mit einer großartigen Frage. Guten Abend, Robert. Grüße dich. Stell die Frage selber, weil ich möchte nochmal lachen.
Als absoluter Grund-User. Also meine Kompetenz und mein Horizont, was Internet und Nutzung angeht, ist recht beengst. Ich weiß, wie ein Internet-Experte funktioniert, aber dann hört es auch schon fast auf. Und genau das gleich würde ich auch der Politik unterstellen, wie jetzt von den Personen wie Frau von der Leyen, die sich dann heransetzen und sagen, ja, Photografie ist scheiße, ist scheiße, definitiv. Mensch, das können wir noch sperren. Aber ich frage mich, ob das nicht eine Spirale ist. Was ja schon genannt wurde, war, gut, okay, sperre eine Seite, ja, dann mach ich halt eine neue auf. Ich lenke da vielleicht ein paar Tage voll ab, aber komm dann doch wieder auf den Trichter. Ich will das irgendwie mit Viren oder Toyala vergleichen. Trotz alledem ist mir nie davor gefeilt, dass sich doch irgendjemand dieser Spirale wieder setzt oder sie überlistet und mein Rechner doch auch spioniert oder was auch immer.
Aber es gibt doch auch noch die Frage hier an die Kollegen von CCC, wenn solche Gesetze geplant werden, ausgedacht werden und so, es gibt doch da auch Fachleute, die da durchaus auch ihre fachliche Meinung dazu geben und sagen, wird so nicht funktionieren oder sehe ich das zu naiv?
Also ich kann ja auch mal ein bisschen plaudern, nicht zu sehr, aber es gibt immer das Argument der Provider, naja es sind zu große Datenmengen. Und es ist aber tatsächlich so, dass die Geräte dafür jetzt da sind. Und zumindest in Deutschland müssen solche Geräte, die den Netzwerkverkehr überwachen, die den Netzwerk steuern können, müssen auch angeschafft werden, um bestimmte gesetzliche Auflagen zur Telekommunikationsüberwachung anzuschaffen.
Stichwort Trafikausleitung. Also wenn man irgendwie als ISP die Anfrage bekommt, wir hätten gerne den ganzen Traffic von dem User oder E-Mails von dem User, dann wird er einfach auf diese Hardware gehängt. Und das muss einfach mal funktionieren. Es ist da, es ist Infrastruktur, die existiert, die deploit ist, die man natürlich auch zu anderen Dingen verwenden kann. ISPs machen das in der Regel auch, um mit den Trafficmengen umzugehen, um den Usern trotzdem eine gute Servicequalität zu bieten, um ihnen problemlos nicht drogelndes Voice-over-IP beispielsweise zu geben, während sie gerade mit HTTP oder anderen Dingen ihre Leitungen breit dicht machen wurden.
Um nochmal zurückzukommen und Robert mit ins Boot zu holen, er sagt, er ist Grunduser, was ich sehr sympathisch finde. Ich glaube, ein Tenor oder eine Grundmeinung der Sendung, die jetzt knapp eine Dreiviertelstunde läuft, ist, dass viele Leute sagen, es steht keinerlei Verhältnismäßigkeit zu dem, was sie eigentlich erreichen wollen. Nun gibt es dieses Gesetz, also den Gesetzentwurf, der wird gerade diskutiert und es kann sein, dass es dieses Jahr in irgendeiner Form durchgeht. Hat der Grunduser, wie Robert oder Icke oder wer auch immer gerade zuhört, irgendjemand die Chance zu sagen, ich möchte das nicht, ich glaube, das geht in eine falsche Richtung, kann ich mich irgendwie dazu äußern, außer hier in dieser Sendung oder in einem Webblog?
Das Problem ist, dass es ein sehr heikles Thema ist und dass eine Diskussion darüber dann auch schnell sehr emotional, teilweise auch mit ziemlich widerlichen Argumenten geführt wird. Es gibt wenig Leute, die sich einfach trauen, in die Öffentlichkeit zu stellen und sagen, Kinderpornografie fehltern ist blöd, ist schlecht. Da ist man automatisch erstmal Außenseiter. Das macht die Diskussion darüber auch ziemlich schwierig. Vielleicht braucht Frau von der Leyen auch noch ganz viele Briefe von Internet-Usern, auch von nicht Experten, sondern die auch ruhig ein bisschen naiv sind, sagen, aber Frau von der Leyen, glauben Sie wirklich, dass das was bringt? Sie machen unser Internet kaputt. Vielleicht hilft sowas, wenn sie da viele Briefe kriegt, möglicherweise.
Ist das eine Argumentationslinie, mit der du leben kannst, Robert?
Nein, also sicherlich finde ich es gut, wenn sich Frau von der Leyen mit sowas beschäftigen würde, auch mit kritischen Äußerungen von Usern. Ich gehe aber davon aus, dass es zum einen zeitlich gerade nicht schafft, weil sie sich um ihre sieben Kinder kümmern muss, und zum anderen glaube ich auch nicht selbst, wenn jetzt dieses Verbot in irgendeiner Form eingekippt wird. Das Internet ist für mich ein grenzenloses Netz. Das bedeutet, wenn irgendjemand irgendwelche Inhalte haben möchte, dann wird er sie auch bekommen. Da bin ich mir zu 100 Prozent sicher. Genau, ganz genau, das ist der Fakt. Es ist wie so ein Kleinuniversum. Ich glaube nicht, dass mit was für einem Aufwand auch immer die in der Lage sind, die zu 50, 60, 70 Prozent so zu sichern, für sich selber, also aus ihrer Sicht, dass solche Pseudo-Seiten, wo sie jetzt der Meinung sind, dass denen die kritisch nicht an den Enduser geraten. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen.
Gut, aber da muss ich ja noch mal einhaken. Das ist ja auch die Argumentation vom Ministerium, dass er sagt, wir wollen ja gar nicht alles blockieren, wir wollen ja gar nicht perfekt sein, wir wollen einfach nur ein paar Prozent sperren. Das ist ein ganz einfaches Mittel, da gibt es diese Listen, die werden in die Provider geschickt und es reicht uns, wenn wir ein paar Prozent davon abhalten, diese Sachen anzuschauen und dafür auch kein Geld fließen kann. Und dann haben wir das Ziel schon erreicht.
Aber das Gegenargument, was genau an dieser Stelle kommt, wäre doch zu sagen, damit wird aber das eigentliche Problem gar nicht erkannt, bekämpft und bearbeitet, sondern es passiert nichts mehr. Außer einer quasi einer Pseudo.
Genau, man kann sich denn zurücklehnen und sagen, wir haben was gemacht.
Wir haben was gemacht. Natürlich kann es nicht perfekt sein, aber wir haben uns da reingehängt.
Genau, das ist ja das, was gerade passiert und was wir jetzt auch seit anderthalb Stunden hier kritisieren. Und ihr auch.
Robert, danke dir für den Anruf. Nächster am Telefon ist Niklas, der musste auch schon ganz schön lange warten. Hallo Niklas, guten Abend. Ich hoffe, du bist nicht sauer, dass du hier ein bisschen in der Leitung gehangen hast. Alles klar. Wie stehst du zu der Thematik Zensur im Internet?
Ja, also was ich noch anmerken wollte, was ich für die eigentliche Gefahr halte, ist, dass man so ein Stückchen das Vertrauen ins Internet insgesamt verliert. Also es gibt natürlich noch viele andere Gründe, warum man nicht allem trauen sollte, was man im Internet liest. Aber ich hatte da vor kurzem so ein Beispiel. Ich habe von eurem Kollegen Tim den Podcast gehört über diesen DECT Hack und wollte auch mal auf dieser Seite, dected.org, vorbeischauen, wo es die ganzen Papers gibt und die Software und so weiter. Und die war irgendwie vorletzte Woche schlecht erreichbar. Also ich habe es mehrmals versucht. Das ging dann gar nicht. Oder es gab auch irgendwelche obskuren SSL-Fehlermeldungen.
Die war wahrscheinlich schwer gefragt, die Seite.
Ja, das ist natürlich die wahrscheinlichste Erklärung erstmal. Aber man kommt da natürlich schon so ein bisschen ins Nachdenken.
Du siehst Gespenster.
Das ist schon so ein kontroverses Thema ein bisschen. Und so der ein oder andere Innenminister könnte so was schon als Gefährdung der öffentlichen Sicherheit ansehen. So ungefähr als ob es eine Bombenbauanleitung wäre. Und darum geht es mir eigentlich. Also wenn so ein System erstmal richtig etabliert ist, dann gerade wenn es intransparent ist, weiß man nicht mehr so genau, ob ein bestimmter Inhalt jetzt bloß aus irgendwelchen technischen Gründen nicht erreichbar ist oder ob er einem vorenthalten wird.
Damit alle anderen wissen, worüber Niklas redet, kaosradio.ccc.de da mal auf den Blog gucken bzw. auf kaosradio.express und dann könnt ihr euch den Podcast zum Deckpack auch noch anhören.
Also nochmal ganz kurz, ich kann dieses Gefühl, oder das ist ein Gefühl, was wir jetzt vielleicht gar nicht kennen und das ist wahrscheinlich ein Gefühl, was wir dann auch erst kennen werden, wenn diese Seiten mal gesperrt sind. Also das ist so ein ganz komisches, Moment, Internet, da klickt man halt irgendwas, dann kommt es. So, aber was ist das für ein Gefühl, wenn dann irgendwelche Sachen plötzlich nicht kommen? Oder ich klick dann irgendwo, denke, vielleicht ist es irgendwo Sticheln, ist plötzlich unter Beobachtung. Und das ist natürlich ein nachvollziehbar komisches Gefühl auf jeden Fall.
Also es gibt ja diverse Länder, andere Länder, die schon Zensursysteme am Laufen haben. Das ist auch unterschiedlich. Also zum Beispiel in den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten scheint es tatsächlich so zu sein, dass man dann tatsächlich so eine Fehlermeldung bekommt. Nee, darfst du nicht angucken, geht hier nicht, ist unmoralisch und so. Während in China läuft es tatsächlich so, dass es dann einfach aus Benutzerperspektive so aussieht, wie eine technische Störung. Also dass dann vielleicht jeder Zehnte schon noch durchkommt. Und die breite Matte aber eben zu faul ist, wirklich zu versuchen, sich die Inhalte zu besorgen. Darauf wird dann gebaut. Und ich würde auch sagen, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich nur um Kinderpornos geht, dann kann man das schon sperren, aber wir haben das ja in der letzten Zeit bei diversen Sicherheitsgesetzen und Überwachungsgesetzen erlebt, dass sich das immer mehr ausgedehnt hat und auf immer mehr Tatbestände angewendet wird. Und ich fürchte einfach, dass dann in ein paar Jahren zum Beispiel vor einem G8-Gipfel die Attack-Homepage so ein bisschen schwer erreichbar sein wird.
Dinge, die möglicherweise alle passieren könnten. Wir wissen es heute alle noch nicht, in diesem Januar 2009, aber wir können darüber reden. Und genau an diesem Punkt heute auch die Diskussion um Chaosradio darüber los treten. Zumindest versuchen ein paar Denkanstöße dazu zu geben. Niklas, danke dir für den Anruf. Und schönen Abend noch. Weil uns läuft jetzt ein kleines bisschen die Zeit weg, weil die Kollegen vom Night Flight stehen schon vor der Tür, die hier gleich Beats basteln werden. Das heißt, kurz in die Runde noch mal so eine kleine Fazitgeschichte, bzw. Schrägschrig, haben wir irgendwas ganz Dringendes vergessen, was wir dringend noch erwähnt müssen?
Nö, außer, dass wir uns noch über Mails von euch freuen an chaosradio.ccc.de. Das heißt, wenn ihr noch was zum Thema uns mitteilen wollt, chaosradio.ccc.de. Ansonsten gibt es noch mal alles zum Nachhören, Mitlesen, Schreiben und überhaupt alles über Chaosradio unter chaosradio.ccc.de.
Und den Podcast zur Sendung, und den gibt es auch bei fritz.de. Ja, wenn ihr durchsindt, dann sind wir hiermit durch. Und verbleiben mit einer Frage für die Nacht, die jeder mit unseres Kopfgesen nehmen kann. Wollen wir uns in Zukunft blinder Zensur einfach anzutrauen? In der etwas naiven Hoffnung, das Internet bleibt deswegen sauber. Chaosradio, das war's. Nächstes Chaosradio gibt es am 25. Jahr noch mal, glaube ich, wenn ich richtig gerechnet habe.
25.
Februar, ganz genau, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. chaosradio.ccc.de Danke Frank, danke Nibbler, danke Andreas und danke auch an Florian, der hier mit uns kurz telefoniert hat. Bis dann, machts gut. Tschüss.